when i was talking to people he said it
was 33 people on the last
part of the auction you guys came at the
end with 69 million dollars
how you guys made the decision to want
to buy people's
every days on the christie's auction
everybody says we both bought it
the money is medical ones how do you
look at money yourself if you're an
asset owner
everything is going up and you think
that you're becoming richer
but it means that we've been inflating
everything around us but in this world
today if you don't make two thousand
dollars a month you are homeless
that's a huge problem pretty intense on
what you just said right
i was so afraid because i knew that it's
a tax trap because once i move into it
it becomes very hard for me to take me
off because they want information of all
my assets now
in singapore i don't even have to say
what assets i hold
and america is very different it's
between the rising nations now of the
east
and the declining nations of the west
[Music]
so you know a lot of people go out there
buy a nice belt people say wow you can
afford to buy 500
bills some people go buy nice thousand
dollar shoes they'll say wow you can
afford to buy a thousand dollar ship
someone buy ferrari you can afford a
ferrari someone buy a million-dollar
home
you can afford to buy a million-dollar
home but only two people
were able to afford to buy a 69
million dollar nft and they're here
today one of them
rumor has it is a crypto billionaire
due to ethereum maybe we'll get into
that but metacogen
and tubador with their names being
vignesh
and anand but the two of the medecovin
and tubador
a few weeks ago shocked the world by
buying beeples
every days for 69 million dollars we got
a lot of things to talk about today with
that being said
gentlemen thank you so much for being a
guest on valuetainment
thank you thank you for for having us
yes so
is it true that the jacket you have on
is actually a crypto jacket tell us
about the jacket you got on
thanks for noticing i think the yeah
okay yeah
so this this one is from meta factory
which is
which is a very crypto native brand so
it's it's it's a brand that produces
fashion for through
as a community first thing right so it
connects artists
and it it sells these kind of uh jackets
uh t-shirts
like sweatpants uh even sneakers
all very designer uh style but
by connecting artists directly you know
to the to the producer so it's like a
merchandise brand
but it's the the interesting part is you
know it's it's arranged as a
dao which is a decentralized
organization so you could you can own
part of the
next interesting brand in the world i i
i'm
it's not again it's not investment
advice but you know i have a little bit
little part of tokens from that uh
company also i think fashion is getting
decentralized so
this is this was the first jacket a
bomber jacket from
from them it's called the the genesis
edition jacket
they're only 40 in the world you know
like um and and it's a
it has a rfid chip and and it connects
to the blockchain through an nft so
there's an nft that points to my address
on the ethereum blockchain and it's a
physical piece
so i think this is a very interesting
trend here right like a physical
digital um a combination so
this is happening there are a lot of
these things happening with sneakers etc
let me ask you is is it an expensive
piece or no the jacket
the good part is i i paid 600 for it but
i made my money back just on the token
appreciation
i got you know it's like a you you get
back some tokens and that
you know it goes up so it's good good so
so you know to to the world by the way
you are you guys family are you guys
friends
no no i we have friends you're friends
okay
so at what point did you guys make a
decision to say
hey let's buy this every day's
and was there a number where you said we
got to stop at this number or were you
saying
we got to own this no matter what so
walk me through how you guys made the
decision to
want to buy people's uh every days on
the christie's auction
sure sure i think i've let tubador talk
about that because he was the
you know he's always the guy who i
talked to
when i it's like i i i get the idea but
he has this
he pushes me into the decision right so
he is my conviction so
i let him talk through it sure that's a
very gentle way of saying i'm the devil
on his shoulder patrick
okay nice very nice pushing him to do
stuff
uh it's been a fascinating journey in
the nft space right
and and to be clear uh while everybody
says we both bought it
the money is medic ones my job is to be
a truffle sniffer in this in this jungle
of unique digital assets
uh and i've gotten pretty good at it
because i love these
artists i love these these brands of art
and that's that's kind of how the
journey started and uh
people we had an experiment with him
with the b20 project which
already discussed with people some time
ago what we
came to realize through that experiment
and also you know in
the way we uh sort of approached people
is that
he's practically the artist of our
generation
which is the digital native generation
right and
the whole concept of the everydays the
the 5000 every days
was a massive hopeful metaphor for this
generation
i mean if you look at the art piece from
the top left begin at it
the first image is pretty crap but then
you trace it all the way through you can
trace the journey of an artist his
entire lifetime
this almost spiritual commitment to this
particular thing that he does
every day right his good days his bad
days his sick days his healthy days
he's putting out art every day every day
so what it told us
is you can start anywhere but you
work with discipline with conviction
with a kind of single-minded passion
and you will hit the end of the rainbow
whether it's the end of a year
or 10 or 13. so that was a very powerful
message for us
and this is why we felt that the space
was precious not just because it was an
nft
or just because it was a purely digital
form of art
but because of the of the story that it
contained within it
now you know to the people that are not
in your world
by the way when i was talking to people
he said it was 30 33 people on the last
day that were
part of the auction that were going
through the whole thing back and forth
and then at the end obviously you guys
came at the end with 69 million dollars
how many people are in the crypto world
like if there was a number to the crypto
community what number would you put to
that
uh you mean are you asking for the
number of collectors
uh or people in general the population
yeah i i would say both because to me i
would want to know
one what is the total population of
crypto that's believers people who
believe in crypto and then the second
one would be
how many are in the world of actually
buying nfts like you guys have been
buying
if you can break that down for example
if you were to say there's about
you know a million people that own a
crypto hypothetically
but there's only 32 000 that are buying
you know nfts like we're buying it do
you guys kind of have that number or no
yeah yeah it's it's a hard number to
give but i feel like it's in the
uh it should be in the tenths of
millions so it could be 50 60 million
people
who i think are uh are
they just don't own uh crypto but you
know they are more
uh understanding of of what's happening
here etc
and maybe uh even a larger population
around 150 million
people who hold crypto because you know
maybe they
they're in it for the money right like
so that
that's that's the number i don't think
it's it's more than that
um and nft space is a very small sub
niche
of this all of this so not more than say
say 50 000 people at this point uh who
are
uh who either hold a nft or
or even if you take the total number of
artists
it's still going to be around that
number and the collectors who really
have the real money now that's even
smaller it will be less than
say 100 less than a hundred got it okay
so i'm i'm looking at right now where
you know different art
articles comes up here's one article
that says from cbs
there's a hundred thousand bitcoin
millionaires right anybody that has a
million dollar or more
in bitcoin do we at this point know how
many
crypto billionaires are out there or no
so it's a very hard uh it's it's it's
hard to calculate that one because of
the pseudonym entry right like
you you're only seeing addresses on the
blockchain and
all of that is also an estimate where
you know you take the rich list
you just go through the blockchain and
see who has the maximum number of
bitcoins and
and you estimate that each of these
addresses is a different person
and then you you you're like yeah maybe
um
these are the number of uh millionaires
of billionaires so right now
i don't think uh that there's over um
maybe less than uh 50 billionaires
probably
but the the point is um we don't know
right like we have no idea it could be
different wallets they could have split
their wallets
it could be in more than one blockchain
uh the assets
but i think it will be much much larger
in the next couple of years
as as we are going through this boom
again and
i had this blog post or a tweet from
balaji srinivasan uh who's a very
important person in our industry
he was going for 2000 as the number of
uh
billionaires when bitcoin would hit a
thousand sorry a million dollars
right so say that one more time two
thousand
so you'll get every two thousand billion
years when bitcoin hits
a million dollars oh wow i just
understand what you
okay so so so when bitcoin hits a
million dollars there's going to be 2
billionaires which means the world
currently has as of 2018
it was 2200 billionaires
that means 50 of all billionaires in the
world are going to are going to be
crypto billionaires
now now we are talking yes yeah now
we're talking okay
so that means if it goes the way it does
any of the 50 current billionaires who
hang on
to what they have whether it's ethereum
or let's just say bitcoin
the current billionaires that means
there's going to be a few worth
a hundred and potentially one could even
pass up some of the current richest
people in the world that we have is that
an
accurate assumption in the in the next
decade
i think satoshi who's who who's never
going to touch his bitcoin is
going to be one of the one of the
pseudonymous billionaires right like and
probably the richest person in the world
it'll be hard to
beat him uh and and he's not going to
touch his bitcoin i
i suppose i we don't even know whether
he's still
you know around but you know he has a
very
important account and there'll be lot
more people who who
these people are ideologically you know
like
bought into this movement so in a way i
don't know if they're going to
like sell out and move into another
asset too so they they're going to stay
right
so and yeah it's it's going to be very
interesting
the the next decade by the way do you
guys at this point have an assumption
who satoshi is or no you you're not
really clear who it is
nope i i i really like this
yeah yeah go ahead the truth is we don't
care who he is
that's the beauty of it i mean the the
origin story is a bit of a legend isn't
it
and in a way that's what gives it gives
bitcoin the power that it has because uh
when it comes to programmability or
composability
it's not the most uh smart
cryptocurrency that is
but it's not it's not the most smart
cryptocurrency there is
it's not yeah tell me why programmable
it's it's very simple it's it's like
basic it's like uh
it's it's almost like a a single-celled
microorganism
but it is the first and is the most
powerful because of that
origin story and that that's kind of the
biggest appeal right i mean think of it
this way instead of calling it a
cryptocurrency or a token or a coin
imagine this this sort of the opening of
a documentary from the ashes of
the financial ruin of 2008 emerged this
new alternative
created pseudonymously and then the
creator
disappears off into the sunset never
claiming credit or the upside from his
creation so that's the legend
and that's what gives it its power so if
tomorrow uh
somebody like dubadur looking like me
lands up in in the show and says i'm
satoshi
you don't care yeah you're you're so
okay yeah got it
now the only reason is i've had i think
it's craig wright i had craig right on
and uh you know he claimed he was
satoshi and i got to tell you
i cannot tell you how many hate emails i
got
from people around the world saying what
are you talking about this is not
satoshi it was pretty interesting seeing
that taking place so let's go back to it
so let's go back to it
so you talked about that the moment
bitcoin hits a million there's going to
be 2 000 billionaires we have currently
200 billionaires
so nearly 40 50 40 to 50 percent of
billionaires say by
whenever it hits a million it's going to
be uh from the crypto wealth now
but then you said something you said
there's an element of
crypto investors don't sell
i saw a part where for a guy like you
that's made your money
specifically in the crypto crypto side
of course we'll get into the bitcoin
atms and
what you what you guys did with that but
uh
you don't own any stocks you don't own
any cars
you don't own a house you mean are you
literally
90 of your money is uh you know all in
crypto
99 yeah 99. 99
of all your money's in crypto yeah yeah
personally yeah
so it's funny uh uh when you say that
you'll have a lot of people that'll say
well that's not proper diversification
why are you not diversified but years
ago
i think it was either andrew carnegie or
jay paul getty that said
do not uh do not uh the quote about you
know put all your eggs in one basket
just make sure nobody touches it
because that's how you make incredible
wealth you know you could lose it all if
something happens to but at the same
time you have the biggest upside
why are you 99 all crypto
i'm a fan of and andrew carnegie okay
right
and uh so i'm not an investor right like
i'm not
i'm not the person who's doing something
else in life and doing
this on the side right so this is very
different from my perspective
and how i look at it so i feel like the
whole crypto is a startup
so if we take uh besos for example
or elon musk ninety percent of his
wealth is in tesla
right so it's like it's like saying i i
am part of this industry
and i think i'm i have a
i have a piece of the pie right and so i
will do everything
possible i i have the skin in the game
and my incentives are aligned in the way
so that i can ride with the movement and
i also believe in the movement because
as as tuber was talking about the
picture the 5000 right
it's also the story of crypto and the
story of me right
where how you know like in 2007 when
people started the everyday
i had no money i had no money to buy a
laptop right
so this is very moving to me and it's a
story of crypto
itself i i don't want to take too much
credit in it i'm happy and grateful that
i could have i could see that and you
know like this could have
gone any in in any way but
i i would still be okay with it if this
didn't work out because you know it's
it's like i would have tried something
else and no no one can take away my
experience my knowledge my connections
right
so the good part is i've stayed with it
and i believe that i'm still
very active i'm very young i'm 32 now
probably in in a few years to come i'll
think about what
diversification means to me right and uh
think about you know like what what
physical means to me because there's
also the other aspect now you're talking
to a very
different person from a different side
of the world and there is a lot of
other issues we go through as people
where the government is is not the same
as you know like
the government of the us or or we don't
get the same kind of property rights
right so there are a lot of other things
that go into
my thinking of of of what investment
means
and yeah so all these things together it
will take a long time to explore all of
those
elements right but it's not a
recommendation i'm giving to everyone
saying that you
put all your money into crypto right for
me it's okay because i i
live in it and i i i have the feeling
and whenever crypto goes up and down
people ask me how do you feel
if i think about the price every day i
will have a heart attack
every day right so i don't think about
the price i don't live
in the in the in the graphs i i take a
step back and i'm quite peaceful
yeah it's very obvious and it's felt by
the way you know kudos to you
the your personality and temperament uh
uh
is one that's uh very interest by the
way the picture behind you
that you have there the picture behind
you those pictures tell tell us about
the pictures that you have behind you
sure sure so this is half any uh the
next best thing to satoshi
so he's the guy who who we know uh he he
was the guy who satoshi used to speak to
or forums and
and email and uh he was almost the
second
uh the second important person right
like yeah like the second person who
landed on the moon
so he's the guy and we have a picture of
him so it's it's it's
i like to i i like to have a picture
with him
you have a picture no no i mean i mean
he's no more
okay he's no more so i've not had the
chance to meet him but i mean
it's at at least we know his face right
and i think people should know his face
because we only talk about satoshi
he's an important person and uh yeah
here
i have warren buffet even though he
hates uh bitcoin i hate
i really love i
agree to disagree with him
and and this is abdul kalam who's my
inspiration growing up he's a he's a
scientist he's a rocket man of india
he's the guy who made uh him he who who
made the first rockets that
uh that india launched and uh he also
uh rose to become the president of the
country
right and so he's a huge inspiration he
started as a fisherman he comes from a
fisherman
home and and his path is very inspiring
and
very righteous too and the guy in the
middle is my model compass
he's called thiruva liver he's 2500
years old
and so he he wrote this beautiful book
called tirukkural
which has thousand three hundred and
thirty seven word
poems and it's a it's the dictionary of
life so you wanna understand friendship
you just you know like a dictionary you
you go there and you get something so it
gives me a lot of clarity
when i need it in my life you're very
deep guy by the way good for you
there's a lot of depth in your uh in
your character that's very impressive
you know you said something earlier
about
the government you said are you are you
currently in india or where are you
currently at i've heard you talk about
singapore i've heard you talk about
different places where are you currently
at
i'm in i'm in singapore uh okay tuber um
if you want to talk about it
yeah you're in india or you're also in
singapore
i'm in india you're in india so what do
you think about the reuters article that
came up
a few days ago i'm sure you saw it this
was uh uh
actually was two weeks ago india to
propose
cryptocurrency ban penalizing miners
trade source this was in new delhi
mumbai
india will propose abandoning
cryptocurrency and uh
finding anyone training in the country
or even holding such digital assets a
senior government official toward
reuters
in a potential blow to millions of
investors piling into the red hot
asset class what do you think about it
and can they actually do it is it
creating any kind of momentum in india
okay uh it this feels like deja vu
patrick because it's happened a couple
of
years ago uh it's it's more only
it's merely an over correction at this
point because uh there are obviously a
lot of
pitfalls when it comes to crypto mainly
because
bitcoin is bad at marketing right it
doesn't belong to any single person so
the only things that
make it to the news are the you know the
scams or the
you know the crashes uh or the hacks
so that's the issue but that said i
india is a very ambitious country so i
have a lot of faith in that
ambition and uh technically we missed
the iit revolution we were relegated to
the back office for all practical
reasons i think this is another
opportunity for us and
i don't think we will make the same
mistake again at least i hope not
yeah you know it's it's i don't know
it's the number seven economy in the
world today number eight seven
six you're you're right there and uh
when i went to mumbai
and i spoke at iit with divyang turakia
uh arundhati bashari i don't know if i'm
even saying the name correctly she was a
former chair
chairman of state bank of india and we
were sitting there talking
the desire to want to develop things and
create with these young kids you're
looking in their eyes you see the fire
in their eyes you don't see
that kind of fire uh in a lot of places
they're just so hungry to want to do
something with it it was very
interesting
getting this spirit when i was in india
to see that taking place so
so uh vignesh medicoven did you
did you move from india to singapore or
are you
from singapore did you grow up in
singapore no no i grew up in india
actually i grew up in a small town in
india
not not a city and yeah i slowly moved
from india to
uae uh studied there for a while and
then to canada
i spent some time there and now i live
in singapore for
like i've lived here for a few years now
and all
all like except the dubai thing
everything crypto right right
yeah why why singapore
um definitely because um singapore is
one of the
best countries to uh live in if if you
are in crypto right now
right there are few countries which are
which are very positive and favorable
and uh very open about it so uh
in terms of regulations guidelines and
and taxes also
um there is also this i don't know how
like there's this whole pos
movement going on which is which is like
moving away from the mining
um like the electricity intensive mining
to
you know like just mining through your
stake right
to for the blockchain so that moment
what has happened is
you know you you can be part of that and
be a miner and singapore allows you to
you know as an individual or
or arena even a company if it's not a
business
you don't get you know taxed on those
those kind of gains etc
and uh capital gains is really nice they
are worri
like there is no capital gains i mean
and um there is no capital gains in
singapore
no no capital gains no and uh income
taxes
is very favorable it's 22 percent at the
highest level
so you know and i don't have a lot of
income so
it's good for me so so in other words
[Laughter]
so in other words are you a uh you must
be
a very much of a pro-capitalism guy
definitely i'm very uh i'm not
libertarian i think i'm cent center
right like and and very
pro-capitalist yeah very cool so so
we've covered a lot of different things
by the way you know it's the the best
part about you is
when you're talking to folks and you see
a lot of the interviews just why'd you
buy it why did you buy it why did you
buy it but then when you go deeper into
your belief system who you guys are
there's a lot of strong
you know you guys are real true
believers so walk me through this idea
of you know a virtual real estate
virtual museum virtual like are you
are you seeing that because i know you
guys have created some kind of a virtual
museum
why don't you start on that first and
then i'll ask my follow-up question to
it
you have a virtual museum and some
virtual real estate sure sure
so this whole uh journey of uh of nfts
and
the virtual world i'm a huge fan of uh
you know
this this idea of of the metaverse right
in general
uh definitely i i i come from that world
of snow crash
you know like ready play one that kind
of a inspiration
um i don't think the world needs to be
that dystopian for
for you know to for ready player want to
happen but the interesting part is that
the like instead of thinking about it as
a as a
um you know like a replacement of the
physical world or something
it's it's a borderless world right like
a borderless world
of expression where there is very little
censorship and and things are
unconfiscatable
right so from that angle of of being
see it's it's a newborn it's a new
street
right so historically
artists that were able to talk
talk to people directly and over time
different countries have very different
perspective on it right like
i would say who owns the wall defines
what kind of society you are living in
so if you go to say
i don't know about the us but i don't
know who can paint on the wall
right maybe graffiti is illegal right or
graffiti is
is frowned upon but not punishable
there are different kind of rules and in
india the walls are owned by the
politicians
right like walls are painted everywhere
but only the politicians have control
over them right
so you'll see their names everywhere so
it's very interesting as an image maybe
next time you're india you'll
you'll notice that and if you go to
berlin the walls are owned by the artist
right so it's a very different
environment and i think it
it talks to the it talks to the
generation and talks to talks to a
different set of people
right and and the and the younger
generation um
are always looking for you know some
kind of defiance
right and this defiance usually in the
physical world
could become violent and and and could
create a lot of issues
but on the meta was what happens is
because of this free expression
it's it's all it's all a graffiti world
right it's a huge graffiti wall
and all these artists from across the
world it's not from
uh there is no geographical limit here
right so what happens is a person from
japan
might might do a gallery a person from
india might do a gallery person from
italy might do a gallery and there could
be cross
um pollination of all these ideas
and then you all meet there right and
you and you look at this
look at what is happening around you and
and
it moves you right like it it's it talks
to you
so it's basically we are just
discovering art
um again and and and that sensor
abilities
is going away um and because it's also
unconfiscated
that means that you know spots in the
meta verse the virtual world
becomes like an address for the artist
so
they could be thrown out of twitter
thrown out of facebook right
but a spot in the virtual world because
it's owned by you
through an nft nfts need not be just
added it can represent the land title
in the virtual world so because you own
it
no one can just take that away from you
and so
you can give that as your address a url
that points to the spot in the meta
verse can be
the address of an artist so every you
know that you can find him
and and you can let him talk talk to you
through his work
all the time by just visiting that url
again right
so i think that's very powerful vignesh
let me ask you how do you view money and
currency like what is money to you do
you
do you look at it like the way the
average person looks at money or do you
look at it as like
point scoring in a game like it's just
you know how do you look at money
yourself
actually this this is not a usual
question so i'm going to think think on
it a little bit
but what i would like to say is uh
i'm a huge fan of olafur the the artist
and he had this climate change project
uh which which happened in
uh i think norway is somewhere where you
know he took a glacier
and then put it in front of the front of
the conference hall
that the climate change confidence was
happening and you could see that glacier
melt
it's he made something very obvious
right
and and that's how i feel about money
fiat
is melting fiat is melting in front of
her eyes
and it's non-obvious it's not obvious
because
you don't feel that way everything in
price if you are an asset owner
everything is going up and you think
that you're becoming richer
but once upon a time being a millionaire
was hard
now you know being a billionaire is okay
there's going to be trillionaires now
it's it does not it does not mean
anything
it means that we have been inflating
everything around us and asset prices
have increased
and it does create this you know like
k-shaped
[Music]
issue right where if you are not an
asset owner you are really affected
because you're sitting on the fear
that's melting
right so it's it's similar to the
climate change crisis that way
where we have to understand what's
happening and and crypto almost is the
is the opposite of that right so i
look at money as definitely as a
as a as a measure of what
what you contribute to the society but
again because of all this economic game
there is a little bit of like a lot of
smartness that also is required
where you know to keep your money is not
easy
because people say you know if you're a
fool the world has a way to take the
money away from you
and i think economists do that to you
the government does that to you
so that you don't remind lazy and i
don't think it's there
um it's not it should not be their
paragraph
right what if i'm lazy what if i want to
be not very useful and just stay right
maybe
like i will not be a famous person but i
can i should still be able to live
but in this world today if you don't
make two thousand dollars a month you
are homeless
and that's that's a huge um that's a
huge problem
right because we are part of economy and
i didn't sign up to be part of this
economy we are all
part of this economy very insightful how
do you view america by the way as an
economy from the outset because
you know the advantage you have is
you're in singapore
which is the number one place to be
for capitalists i mean you know the
whole book atlas shrugged if you wanted
to create
the city the closest thing to that city
today
is singapore nothing comes close to it
maybe there's a couple of them you can
make an argument for
but singapore is a place where a lot of
capitalists are going to and and what's
funny is a lot of people who are there
don't want other people to know it's
kind of like don't advertise it just
kind of
let it just be us that we know it but
for you
who lived in india live in singapore you
lived in
uh uh canada i mean i think you lived in
a uh was it uae as well
yeah how do you view america right now
because let me explain a little bit more
deeper on that how do you view america
one
just as america as an economy and
society what direction it's going to
and how do you view it from the
standpoint of you know you got a janet
yellen and some of these
folks in politics who own the wall you
know the way you said who owns the wall
who are wanting to dictate and put
controls on bitcoin so two ways one how
do you use it
view it as a society in the future and
how they're managing
and looking at the crypto yeah so
uh i would i would like to say that you
know like we divide the
world countries in the world into
developed and developing right
so developed almost uh
the the that word feels like it's
complete right
and and developing means it's a it's a
it's just
it's the present tense right like
something is happening yeah
but there is this continuous
uh idea to everything and i think
america
actually kind of missed it in a way in
the
it it's a name brand right america is
definitely a name brand
but after the 70s i think
um if you if like if you are an american
i don't think it's the same uh because
the taxes have
and the tax the way taxes are done today
um
and and the way uh money is is is being
printed
it all it it it is all very
un-american like from an outside on from
an outsider's point of view right
i don't want to um criticize you know
a specific government or or you know
another
another country in the world which i'm
not part of which which i'm not very
happy about doing also but just looking
at it
i was inspired by america you know
every time i i someone talked to me
about america
i was like it used to you know like this
used to be light light bulbs in my head
and and growing up from india
most of the people's dream is to go
settle in america
think about that right like all these
smart people it's like we
we take the society and the cream wants
to go to america
right so it's it's i i feel sometimes
bad about this because i'm like
oh man we have to be in india then then
it will make better sense for india
but all that all that momentum i think
is now slowing down
because of the way the system system has
um you know kind of changed from being a
capitalist system
even though they don't like i feel like
they like america america really hates
the word communism
but there is this there is this spectrum
where it's it's moving towards it right
like all
all of these uh taxation and
all of these handouts uh through uh
from the for and money printing
especially even
even during covet the kind of money
printing that went into it
and from 2008 if you look at how much
money has been printed
that's that's very un-american if you
ask me right
and so if i'm today going to live in
america or an american
it's very i have to pay world taxes so
even if i move somewhere else i have to
pay taxes
right and and it's it's just you know
it's just
using the name brand to you know kind of
it's america for the like it's it's
people for the nation not
not nation for the people right so
that's that's how i feel
and i think when i this one was making
this decision of moving from canada
like i was so afraid to even think about
america
i didn't want to move into america at
all because i knew that it's a trap
a tax trap because once i move into it
it's it becomes very hard for me to
to to take me off because they they
would they want information of all my
assets now
it's like crypto asset they have to
declare them it's not cool
i i'm i'm very pro privacy
so in singapore i don't even have to say
what assets i hold
right only if i have an income inside
singapore i talk to
talk to the government and america is
very different so i feel like it's moved
away from
you know like the the the day and it's
more of a
the rising nations as balaji again would
put
it's it's it's between the rising
nations now of the of the east
uh and and and the declining nations of
the west is how i feel like today
so do you think the way they're going
right now is sustainable or no
definitely not sustainable definitely
necessary because something should
happen to
the fiat system like a lot of people
talk about
crypto as a bubble right but think about
it
crypto is not the bubble it's the pin
to the fiat system so what's happening
now is
if um us prince keeps printing money
and another nation also equally prints
money what how do you
measure you know like inflation
you would just see all the assets going
up and be like oh yeah assets are more
important so they went up in price
the psychology of people cannot be
affected but when you see crypto price
going up
it's it's a mirror it's a mirror to the
system
and it's saying whenever people talk
about crypto and understand it enough
they go to the point where they say oh
it has no intrinsic value
and i tell them wait until you
understand what fiat is
right and the system the fiat system
today is very different from the 1940s
and 1930s
after the brenton woods it's all very
different right
and people have not even gotten to
understand that a lot of people in the
world still think it's it's backed by
gold it's not it's not and
and for for for the rich people usually
they're continuously moving their cash
away
into assets right and and they
continuously think about it and
people don't hold cash at all
but but historically maybe you would
hold cash
a lot of cash when it was maybe back to
gold or something
now it does not make sense it's like a
it's like something on fire right like
you want to give it to someone else
and get something that will not decrease
in value so
it has become like that and it's
accelerating
and once you go into that trap the the
money printing trap from the government
side you know it's like
you know you if you look at the
mainstream media when they
when they talk positive about the
handouts right like
going on what happens is it creates this
sense
of the government helping people and
anyone talking
against it are wrong morally right
but we are not talking about who like
everyone is
is very like i'm that's that's not the
intention the intention is
is this sustainable because we are we
covering up a bigger problem for
tomorrow right
and fiat printing is such a uh
i don't want to use the word diabolical
but it's a
it's it's something that's not obvious
it's something
that's not very very easily
understandable by the
end user and and customer and citizen
so the government can keep doing it for
a while and
one day maybe you know they say like
a slower and then suddenly
fiat would be like that it it we we
could like america could go into
hyper inflation but you know the trust
of the country is still there
so it might it might take years for that
to happen
what what is the next america right now
meaning you know america is really an
idea if you think about it it's not
nothing more than an idea you got a
bunch of land and resources but the
reality of it is
it's a set of ideas written on a
constitution and a paper and then the
world started showing up immigrants like
mice i'm not from here i'm from iran
so i showed up here and i said okay
great i like these set of ideas let me
build my family around this set of ideas
in the in the crypto world and the
community that you're a part of
what what do you guys see as the next
america if if such a thing even exists
do you look at singapore is there other
places you look at
like you almost described what bitcoin
is
right yeah because it's an idea as you
said
i have immigrated into crypto and if you
understand
like that's what this conversation is
about where
i'm trying to reduce my physical
print as much as possible so that
you know it's just a commodity to me the
country
the system everything just becomes a
commodity to me
and i will go to the country which best
serves my
my um ideas that are in this virtual
world
right and the new america if you ask me
is crypto because it allowed an
immigrant
you know to be part of it it does not
say no to anyone
it it is a freak it's a it's it's it has
open borders
right and you can you can go from zero
to becoming really successful in a lot
of ways it's not like
my story is not done
right like it's not it's not like people
should not think about
my story and think oh yeah he was lucky
maybe i was
but you can do today's what is more
important you can start today
and in 10 years you could also be that
is what i'm trying to say
and and people are very welcoming right
like now
why are we inviting artists to be part
of this movement
and why did we why are we doing this nft
and why are we spending so much money
because think about it like this
historically there were kings
and they they were the patterns to art
and they
had like all when we go to a museum
that's what goes into our head now right
like we we look at all this art
and that's our mental model that's very
deep and
and from there we we've had no medium
change
and tech totally missed missed art
i when i say tech i'm differentiating is
from crypto
right tech is different because crypto
is the opposite of tech
it decentralizes crypto decentralizes
tech centralizes
it's it's just corporations which are
like
multinational like governments which
will not
which will not tell that fact outside
right they are just virtual governments
the mncs so what crypto is
is a new kind of nation
and it you you can just get into it and
get out of it
and there is no passport no citizenship
it's just virtual
you just said you just said the tech
companies are virtual governments
wow so so essentially facebook
twitter google is a virtual government
yeah their their citizens like they have
one billion people under them
and they make all the money and it's not
even the money it's the control
they get to dictate the rules
yeah and they control your attention
today
they say data is oil what it's a very
very important statement right when data
is oil
yeah and and and crypto is the opposite
of that
and so when art becomes part of crypto
what we are doing here
is deeper because we are taking this
this moment
as a pattern age moment so we like when
art is coming to this moment
it's going to be a visual we are going
to have this visual language
right it's going to impact the world
visually
it might be the physical world too but
i'm more excited about the metaphors in
that way because
i want to create not not me i want to be
part of this creation
i'll be one of those people but i think
there'll be hundreds of collectors
who create this visual visual
meta verse where a 14 year old would
arrive
from from say iran or say from from
japan
and would would get inspired and become
part of that community
right because where can you go today if
you are from iran you know
about iran right definitely and i i get
very emotional i have friends from iran
too
and you know sometimes i cannot even
send them money
it's you know even crypto but you know
what i mean it's it's
it's a very different world we are
living in and
and that and the crypto world is the new
america as you said
it's a it's where people are welcome
people can find
their destiny
i'm someone explained it that way before
that's that's pretty intense on what you
just said right there you said by the
way you said a lot of different things
and you were what you were a technical
consultant before and in 2003
13 you started with 5 000 5 000 and you
turn it into this
you cannot have just been a technical
consultant are you a reader are you do
you
are you a big researcher are you a
reader
what's in that brain of yours so i'm i'm
i'm a reader definitely uh i
when i when i was growing up maybe when
i was until i was 20 i i could not
english is not my first language right
so uh
i like i could not read very well so
what i
what i did was i started listening to
audio books when i was 20 around 20.
uh it also helped me with my language
right because someone was you know
always speaking in my ears
so it it became a very interesting thing
but
but back then it's all it's all okay now
like i had audible and audible was very
costly for me
i could not afford audible so what i
used to do is they had this one free
book
that you can download if you have a
credit card so i used to borrow so many
people's credit card create these
accounts
for like and and download these audio
books all these uh
economists right like australian
economics so i had no
like idea like i i was i'm an engineer
by
you know like undergrad but economics
and especially uh ludwig juan mice's and
and uh hayek uh hayek is a very
big inspiration in in my life
crazy uh the names you're giving let me
are you guys familiar with bitclout a
little bit but i've not used i don't
know about tuber
i haven't used it yet so so you you know
the whole idea just came out a few weeks
ago which is
you know you're able to invest into
individuals so you're buying
currency in individuals and they went
and got the top
15 000 twitter profiles put it over
there
decentralized no one owns it it's not
like there's an operation going similar
to
bitcoin and you get to buy so the first
person that buys it's a dollar then 2
4 8 16 and it keeps going and they have
a ranking on who's at the top and
uh gradually other people are coming in
not a lot of big names have come in yet
but enough names are coming in that are
recruiting others
can you see a concept like that also
because i think a lot of times right now
when i read about you
i read about the fact that you you
bigger wealth of your bigger percentage
of your wealth was made based on
ethereum you were an early investor in
ethereum
and you had it backed with bitcoin atms
so do you see a bit cloud
being something that could be the next
bitcoin ethereum type of thing because
it seems like a lot of different things
are coming out right now but this is
more investing
in an individual rather than a currency
i think there'll be many forms to it and
uh for
like i've not researched too much into
bit cloud so i've just you know as i've
heard
heard it from here and there uh i would
i would not jump into it definitely
right even even when i used to do
investments
i i used to have a
like it's like yeah from outside it
looks like i'm i'm not diversified
but inside the crypto industry when i
when i move into a new
crypto or a new team i always
have limitations on how much i'll go
into it with
so if it's a new company like bitcloud
and i have no idea who the founder is
i would really really be skeptical about
it like personally
right and even if even if it has a good
idea
and and it can be decentralized the
problem is in a year
there could be a politic it's all crypto
becomes very political quickly
right and there should be a resolution
to how they upgrade stuff
and and if it's if it has this uh crypto
and and a centralized website which
which you know
goes with it or something that's a huge
risk so
that's a red flag for me so i will not
go too much into that
right so i usually look for
who's leading this movement and why what
their intention is
before investing very interesting
very interesting well uh i got to tell
you i've really enjoyed this
uh i can talk to you for hours this is a
very
uh deep insightful conversation probably
the best one i've ever had in the topic
of crypto
and uh we're definitely going to ask to
have you come back
and uh speak and by the way it was very
nice getting to
know you as well you didn't take a long
time for you to say look i'm not the
backer i'm the one that's going out
there finding this stuff and we work
together as a team it shows a lot
in your level of humility of you guys
being able to work
very well together so once again thank
you so much for
you guys coming out and being a guest on
value team and i really enjoyed it
thanks a lot thanks a lot this was a
pleasure probably one of the deepest
conversations i've ever had on the topic
of bitcoin and cryptocurrency i don't
think the topic has gone as deep as
this one went to i mean countries have
walls
in india walls are owned by the
government but in berlin walls are owned
by
artists tech missed a mark on art and
nfd and nft is going to take it because
tech essentially became a virtual
government
u.s used to be free on the ideas but i
don't understand why they're going away
from
just incredible type of a conversation
if you enjoy this video there's two
other videos that you may enjoy one of
them is
the original satan i did with people
who's the artist that sold the nft to
medicoven for 69 million dollars if
you've never seen this click over here
and on a podcast couple weeks ago i was
asked
where i would move to if america failed
if you enjoyed that part of the
conversation with meadowcoven
click over here to see where i would
move to
if america were to fail take care
everybody bye-bye